[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight so if you look at the numbers in
this show we do our best to do that the
most terrifying period of this epidemic
appears to be coming to an end if not
already over the virus of course we'll
still in fact and sicken and kill many
more Americans
nobody should minimize that but the time
for panic and there was one is now over
our greatest fear going into this was
that our entire health care system might
collapse under the strain of new cases
that was a real fear and it was
justified that's why we locked the
country down but that collapse never
came and we are grateful for that the
famous curve they told you about has
been flattened in the meantime though an
awful lot of people have been flattened
themselves badly hurt by our governments
response children are going uneducated
tens of millions people have lost their
livelihoods the whole economy is in
tatters just today oil futures traded at
negative $40 in other words things are
so screwed up that producers couldn't
give it away keep in mind we're not
talking about overpriced handbags in
some boutique this is petroleum which we
need to keep civilization going that's a
measurement of where we are our economy
has shrunk to that point of what we
never imagined would be possible and
that's not a small thing it's a disaster
for all of us so given all of this it's
not surprising and it's not unreasonable
that some people would like to loosen
the lock downs we flattened the curve
let's figure out how to resume our lives
that does not sound crazy because it's
not crazy unless you're the people in
charge or their bodyguards in the media
in which case opinions like that are a
dangerous threat to your power and must
be stamped out immediately and so
recently for example some citizens have
been using social media Facebook to
organize demonstrations against the
severe lockdowns they're currently
living under expressing your views about
the decisions that politicians make is
protected under our Constitution you
could argue in fact it's the whole
reason we have a constitution in the
first place it's literally enshrined in
the First Amendment and for a reason but
Facebook doesn't care Facebook doesn't
recognize the US Constitution it doesn't
recognize our country's centuries-old
norms as CEO Mark Zuckerberg explained
on ABC people who complain about the
lockdown and organize others to do the
same have been removed from
site four for providing quote
misinformation how do you deal with the
fact that Facebook is now being used to
organize a lot of those protests to defy
social distancing defy the search of
business new guidelines in States is
somebody trying to organize something
like that that qualifies wrong for
information we do classify that as
harmfulness information and we take that
down misinformation that's a term that
should give you the shivers it's hatchet
a latarian regimes dismiss views that
threaten their power
that's the country were suddenly living
in the state of new jersey recently
issued criminal charges against a woman
called kim Pugin her crime organizing a
protest against the locked in other
words she criticized the Governor of New
Jersey
so his employees had her arrested are
you comfortable with that
our leaders are come through with it
they applaud it it makes life easier
when your critics shut up and go to jail
they like that in Elizabeth New Jersey
the mayor there is using unmanned drones
to spy on citizens and make certain they
obey that sounds like something they do
in China and they do in fact the drones
are literally from China they're made by
a Chinese company called DJI the
companies donated them to 22 American
states to control unruly voters it seems
obvious those drones must be sending
data back to their masters in China the
Pentagon believes they are they've
banned their use but the mayor of
Elizabeth doesn't care the drones are
helping him consolidate his power he's
for them over in New York City Mayor
Bill DeBlasio doesn't seem to have
drones just yet he may but for now he's
got the next best thing
8 million potential snitches all working
for him
de Blasio has ordered his citizens to
spy on their neighbors and report their
neighbors if they behave in unapproved
ways needless to say it should make you
very nervous when politicians leverage
your fear to make themselves more
powerful in order to terrify you and
they start arresting people for the
crime of disagreeing with them our media
exists to push back against these kinds
of dangerous excesses that's why we have
the First Amendment are we watching a
flu d'etat the press ought to be asking
that question they should get to the
bottom of it but they're not instead
they're cheering on the repression watch
MSNBC explain how anyone who disagrees
with the politicians they like is
needless to say a racist what is it that
they're trying to channel here is this
confesses sort of neo Confederacy and
what the hell does that have to do with
a pandemic America first is a phrase
that was used by Charles Lindbergh and
the the Nazi sympathizers in 1939 1940
41 it became president Trump's rallying
cry you have that on the right when I
look at these protests what I see are a
bunch of white people essentially saying
oh it's affecting those people so why do
I have to change my life for them let's
be honest about what they are they are
the Fox News Nazi Confederate death cult
rump of the Republican Party it's not
that hard unfortunately to turn a health
crisis into a racial ethnic crisis I
think that what they're saying quite
clearly when you see the numbers when
you see the statistics when you see the
CDC data is I want more black and brown
people to die right there that can't if
you want the government to open up then
you want more black and brown people to
die joy readers the biggest race baiter
on cable can you imagine putting that
garbage on your TV channel in the middle
of a pandemic whipping people into a
frenzy of paranoia and hate on the basis
of zero evidence so irresponsible it's
hard to believe it's happening but
here's the bigger theme and you may be
sensing it certain people would like to
use this moment to elevate themselves
and crush you on the view today host Joy
Behar complained that not enough rights
have been abolished during this pandemic
exercising the right to bear arms she
said should be treated going forward as
a felony why are you bringing guns to a
rally you want to call yourself
protesters leave your guns ha those are
terrorists who bring guns two things two
rallies I don't trust that listen to
these people these people should stay
off television until they can get some
critical distance and some wisdom
something awful you're watching it here
and threatening has been unleashed
inside many of the people who lead this
country this isn't the media making
excuses for fascist behavior this is the
media demanding more fascism now
immediately the sad thing is what they
could be doing
we have protests against lockdowns
across this country you may like them
you may not but what does that tell you
why are they happening did Rush Limbaugh
do all that no he didn't
here's the truth if Americans had
confidence that the government's
response to this virus was wise and
thoughtful and thoroughly rooted in
science they probably wouldn't be
protesting against those decisions in
the numbers they are but they don't
believe that and they don't believe it
for good reason when the state of
Michigan bans joint replacements but
encourages abortions and lotto ticket
sales you know more than Sciences going
on here no epidemiologist recommended
that for something else but you wouldn't
guess that from watching most shows on
television the media are not bothering
to report on what we really know or
don't know about the virus it's
fascinating but they're ignoring it and
they're still not holding anyone in
power to account they're not explaining
the science of why it's necessary to
close pools and parks and beaches all
summer why it's scientifically required
to tell citizens to snitch on their
neighbors they're not even addressing
that it said they're lashing out at the
insolence how dare they of their fellow
citizens for failing to silently accept
it all many of the media seem to be
enjoying this crisis and they are it's
been a great opportunity to talk at
great length about their all-time
favorite subject which is themselves and
how much more impressive they are than
you here's that weird little guy on CNN
it wasn't until this Friday night that I
hit a wall and that's when the tears
came so we have nothing to compare this
with so it can be incredibly alarming it
can be incredibly depressing media can
help making media can help do the
emotions are real for everybody
they're a big part of the story Oh barf
this is a guy who got a special
exemption to the government quarantines
he so fervently supports for other
people all of us in the media got that
exemption by the way this is a guy who's
working in a high paying job when tens
of millions of Americans are not working
at all please be quiet your tears are
not quote a big part of the story and
neither are you
for God's sakes please stop talking
about yourself it is unseparable what
they can't stop the most consistent
byproduct of privilege always and
everywhere is narcissism so it's not
surprising that our pampered overlords
just cannot shut up about themselves
Alexander at Casa Cortez doesn't make
sense as a person until you learn that
she grew up as sandy Acacio in an
affluent suburb of West Chester and then
went on to get some silly pointless
degree at a silly pointless private
college of course she did it's so
obvious once you know it Thank You
Wikipedia she is a child of privilege
she's not some kid from the streets
someone who actually grew up in the
Bronx would be far too embarassed to
drone on about herself on Instagram
please suddenly people like sandy Acacio
seem to have a lot more power than they
did before this pandemic arrived from
China that's at least as scary as the
virus itself and its effects will last
much much longer you have a right to
lawfully push back against that and you
should